[Music]
the founder of samsung explained that
the korean anja for the word samsung
means
three stars the star signified something
that was eternal while three was
symbolic for big
numerous and powerful that is precisely
the feeling you'll get when you take a
tour of their headquarters called the
samsung digital city
located in suwon just 30 kilometers
south of seoul south korea's capital
in fact the multinational tech giant has
buildings and developments in other
nearby cities like yanjin and huasun
together the space occupied by samsung
in these regions is referred to as
samsung digital valley
our tour of the city revealed to us a
similar work ethic like that of silicon
valley however the level of care
afforded to employees in the digital
city is perhaps rivaled by no other
company and the effect of samsung's
presence to the locals
is also a highly positive relationship
welcome back to our channel if you
haven't already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and ring that bell so you're notified
every time we upload a new video now you
probably know samsung is one of the most
recognizable and top cell phone
manufacturers and over the years they
have proven to have earned that status
through many of their sleek designs and
innovations in the mobile phone industry
while some of their products have just
straight up been the bomb
however samsung is much more than that
samsung electronics may be the largest
information technology in consumer
electronics maker by revenue but other
large affiliates exist too
for instance samsung heavy is the second
largest shipbuilding company samsung
engineering and samsung cnt corporation
are two of the largest construction
companies worldwide while samsung life
insurance
is the 14th largest insurance company in
the world so you can understand when the
office space in samsung's suwon
headquarters alone
covers 390 acres almost four times as
large as the vatican and similar an area
to monaco
samsung digital city is located in suwon
which is the last completely walled city
in the country the wall is a unesco
heritage site and as a tourist
attraction it is the other
reason besides the presence of samsung
in the city that draws so many
foreigners to suwan during the korean
war
samsung facilities in seoul were so
damaged that the samsung founder
libyan chol had to move from the capital
city to sawan in 1951 by 1969 the
company would diversify its interest
so samsung electronics could be born and
its headquarters naturally was fixed
within the walls of the city
and saved it from destruction eventually
with the growth of samsung the arrival
of other subsidiaries and departments
and the effect of the companies on the
lives and employment of the people in
the city samsung digital city has
evolved to accommodate the explosive
economic metamorphosis
in fact two other cities now also house
semiconductor factories for samsung
electronics
samsung nano city in yanjin and samsung
nano city in huasun
both cities are just a few kilometers
from suwon and they reflect the fact
that samsung really has spread out its
roots in south korea like a tree from a
little seed
now in samsung digital city there are
about 35 000 employees
four landmark towers over 130 buildings
that include labs
offices recreational facilities a guest
house for visiting researchers and other
facilities in the city that cater to the
large workforce
one of my favorites is the availability
of over 150 teachers looking after the
children of some of the employees
because if you have 35
000 people in a large area unless those
35 000 people are these guys
chances are that they have children
amongst them that's a very important
step they've made
just like the resting rooms for
employees with special treatments for
pregnant women
life is meant to be easy and work is
part of life so it's great to see that
you can easily transport yourself to 103
different destinations on any of the 500
shuttle buses in samsung digital city
but what does work look like in this
place
well there's a memo chamber where galaxy
phones are tested
the memo or multiple input and multiple
output chamber is where radio links like
4g
lte are experimented on speaking of
connectivity and experimentation the
most feared internet connectivity
5g has its own testing space called 5g
city
in 5g city samsung workers experiment on
how to get the technology up and running
for the things it would be useful for
like the internet of things or iot iot
will create interconnected objects that
will be able to exchange data wirelessly
and do awesome stuff
like your fridge and your smartwatch
conspiring to advise you from eating
late at night
and save your life what a diabolical and
despicable
technology there's also the an
echoic chamber which works to get the
best conditions for the radio tests of
samsung electronics
it does this by absorbing both sound and
electromagnetic waves
thus eliminating every form of
reverberation or echo and simulating an
infinitely large room
the name an echoic is derived from the
fact that the room
lacks any echo and you wouldn't believe
the amount of work that went into the
sounds for samsung electronics because
there's a whole team of music artists
and producers working daily in the
company's sound lab to develop even the
tiniest of sounds that you get from a
samsung device
the voicing of bixby samsung's virtual
assistant your chat notification
the sound of your air conditioner
turning off the sounds from your smart
tv
name it these guys have got it covered
the digital city also has the samsung
innovation museum where you can time
travel through the rich history of
innovation at the company since its
inception in 1938
and there are also older objects from
270 years ago that will
inspire anyone looking at them as they
basically tell the story of human
ingenuity
this is the kind of inspiring
environment that the employees work in
and there's more employees have access
to free healthcare services like flu
shots
dental treatment physicals and
traditional acupuncture
it gets even more healthy as employees
can engage in a variety of sports with
many sporting facilities like the ten
basketball courts
four badminton courts two baseball
diamonds three soccer fields
and an olympic-sized swimming pool there
are also over 650 employee clubs where
workers indulge in once in a lifetime
fantasies
like paragliding or regular hobbies like
photography
there are also many events from rock
concerts to a string quartet you'll bump
into every now and then in the city's
many open spaces
the most loved event is family day where
the entire samsung digital city gets
turned into a theme park
and employees even ride around in
go-karts and have fun with their friends
and families
i'd be tempted to say that family day is
the ultimate inspiration
but that would be food and samsung knows
this as well
that's why they have a 4 000 seater
cafeteria with almost 100 different
delicacies on its menu
the company serves over 72 000 meals
over the course of breakfast
lunch and dinner and the food is the
biggest inspiration not just because it
fills the bellies of the employees
it also fills the bellies of locals
living around the towns of suwan
yangjin and wasoon you see serving 72
000 meals every day creates a large
demand for food stuff which the local
farmers are more than willing to supply
this is part of a long history of the
company's positive influence on the
country
take for instance the fact that samsung
is considered as the major driving force
behind the company's economic resurgence
also called the miracle of han river
samsung and its affiliate companies are
responsible for a fifth of south korea's
exports and the company's revenues have
been estimated to be about 17
of the country's total gdp samsung cnt
has a major hand in south urban
development
building over 200 000 houses in the
country since the 80s
the importance of the company's presence
in the country cannot be overstated
but it can be summed in the way that a
washington post headline once put it
in south korea the republic of samsung
but we all know it goes beyond the
borders of the land of the morning calm
samsung is immense and we can see how
their attention to giving their workers
the best in their digital city
and digital valley has driven innovation
and a brilliant work ethic that has
helped them take over several sectors of
industry in the world
i personally like samsung's headquarters
not just because it's awesome
but because any apples you see here are
healthy
and the windows here are transparent
what do you think of this digital city
where would you prefer to work other
than here also do you think tesla's new
starbase city will give it a run for its
money
let us know in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video
make sure to give it a like and check
out more awesome ones on the simply tech
channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time